(audience applauding)
Drew, I am so honored and thrilled
to be sitting here talking to you.
I mean, to have watched you as a young child
and seen all these iterations of your life
and the way you've handled everything,
like I'm so excited,
like I have chills talking to you right now.
I'm so excited.
Thanks for having me.
Okay, I had a whole question lined up for you
and now my mind just went blank
'cause I'm living in the bliss of that.
And that makes me wanna go to a different question which is,
I love that you've embraced this notion of your book
about second acts.
And the reason what you just said meant so much to me
is because I think about it in tandem
with this notion that you're putting out
so strongly into the world
and really owning and running with this concept that
I think we all need to really buy into and believe
because it gives us the courage to change our tracks
when it seems really scary and intimidating,
we don't want to ditch everything we've learned
and known or that's safe,
how do we take that risk, Patricia?
You know, this is so interesting because
the pandemic gave everyone this pause in their life,
men and women, and by the way of any age
to take assessment of
how they've been spending their precious time
and we've all realized how precious life is
through this pandemic and how precious our families are.
And I feel that a lot of people,
and I know that a lot of people have thought
when we can get back to life again,
I'm not sure I want to be living it
the same way I was doing before the pandemic.
But how do I change that?
And so there's these wonderful stories in "Your Second Act"
really inspirational stories by people I've known personally
and others that I just heard
about who I invited to be part of the book
who, because of financial circumstances,
medical circumstances, you know
just various reasons have had to pivot.
And, you know, I feel like you've done that in so many ways.
Like, I don't know, you're like on your fifth act
and the only thing left for you to do
is become an international spy.
I mean, I think that's going to be your sixth act.
By the way,
thank you for giving me a brand new goal.
I really love "Your Second Act"
which just came out in paperback
and we're celebrating that today,
because risk-taking is great,
but how we take that risk is really the key.
So thank you for really actually writing a manual
on how to do it.
You're welcome
Now, okay.
It's Mother's Day and we're just all moms.
You have four sons?
Yes.
I know, and it's so funny when you're talking about tattoos
because you know, I'm a little bit older than you Drew
and I had said to my sons from the beginning,
I saw this tattoo thing starting to really
infiltrate the culture
and when I was growing up,
only sailors and bikers got tattoos.
I literally said to my boys,
anybody gets a tattoo is out of the will.
(audience laughing)
Wait, so how's that going?
Okay, so there's only two left in the will.
(audience laughing)
No, actually my oldest son went to college
and he came home for Thanksgiving break
and he came to the set of "The Middle"
when there were a hundred extras on the set
so that I couldn't get angry at him
and announced that he had gotten a tattoo.
So smart, oh my God, what a smart boy.
Smart guy, of course he had all the crew members
coming over saying like, hey man, cool tattoo,
and they all started showing him their tattoos.
So I was like,
okay, first of all we have to finish the scene,
so I can't even respond.
And then he showed me the tattoos,
it's like five eyes, like just an eye,
in five in a row on his forearm.
Like an eye eyes?
Yes, like an eye, yeah.
That's sounds really cool.
Well, okay thanks Drew, thank you.
Sorry.
It's original and unique, does it represent something?
Okay, so that's what I said,
okay, I said, at least tell me
that it means something and I could see him in his mind
like all he thought was, oh, that's cool.
So he goes like each eye represents my,
one of the members of our family and I'm like,
you're BSing me.
And so he has a few more and another son has a few more,
and you know, who knows?
Anything can happen.
If I do, Drew if I get one, it's going to be massive.
I do it, I am going all the way.
Gosh, I wish you were here today.
I wish I could strap you to that table of Ryan.
One of the most famous tattoo artists in the world,
I mean, by the way I heard your sons have recently
also gotten on dating apps.
Is that true?
No, listen, you know, I'm getting up there and
I'm like it's going to be a while before I have grandkids,
I stopped drinking because I thought
I need to keep my brain like solid
because the grandkids aren't going to be here for another
10 or 15 years.
I don't even know that.
And I don't want to be that
like drooling nana in the corner,
who everyone just walks over and kind of, you know,
has to give her a kiss and then, you know,
I just want to be involved and active.
So yeah, but they don't even have girlfriends yet.
Two of them said they signed up for dating apps
and I was like yes dating apps.
My husband and I are those weirdos who would like if we're
walking down the street and we see somebody with a baby,
we like stop and have to smell their head and you know,
you know, people are like, that's a pandemic,
stay away from my kid, but we both have baby fever.
I love it.
(upbeat music)